[Music]
a uk mother was complaining about a back
ache and hours later
woke up in a hospital with doctors
telling her she may have to get all four
of her limbs amputated oh my god did she
get like a [ __ ] parasite or something
like that in her like inner inner spine
not a parasite and it's not something
super unique or like
it's not a one in a million thing either
how old is she
34
it's common enough uh if this if this
happens toxic shock syndrome
oh [ __ ] sadie kemp 34 she was laughing
and enjoying her festive dinner with her
family just hours before she collapsed
in pain turns out she got septic shock
from a kidney stone oh
they're crazy and uh it was causing her
the skin on her arms and legs to go
necrotic so oh [ __ ] hurt wait she
didn't notice this [ __ ] no it did it
within hours oh
and that's that's really abnormal
oh my god it's it's like a worst case
scenario from a common thing that god i
gotta get i gotta get it it's like one
of those yeah a few hours yeah so what
did that like did it plug some areas and
it just started [ __ ] rotten the limbs
i guess the way that uh sepsis works um
i mean if someone of you guys knows more
about it like chime in but like poisons
the system it just kind of neglects
other areas of your body to fight an
infection that thinks is like
centralized somewhere so then you start
losing
life function on the [ __ ]
that's why your digits go yeah it's like
being bit by a shady salamander or
something what i'm sorry what oh you're
shady what would you categorize as a
shady salamander i don't know dude kind
of like sketchy [ __ ] sound has been
chewing on nails and dookies [ __ ]
bites
and your skin's like
this is the amount of time 2 30 p.m
she's with her family having dinner 5
p.m she's fighting for her life geez god
damn did you remember that jk news we
did where dude scratched his leg
on a [ __ ] trash bag that he was
taking out oh yeah yeah yeah then he got
[ __ ] septic [ __ ] toxic shock [ __ ]
yeah from that little infection
that's what happened to the leader of
the midnight mission in downtown the
homeless outreach we got bit by
homelessness
i don't think that's where this is going
two reasons how this guy's leg amputated
from uh infection oh
oh that's uh so [ __ ] scary yeah so as
this is happening to her the doctors
scramble to like try to fight what's
going on in her body they were able to
save like the major parts of her limbs
but they had to get rid of her uh
fingers oh yeah so she has everything
she actually looks like she's have no
fingers that's her yeah right there
she's got more than what they initially
pitched her so let me see yeah they
thought that she was gonna have to lose
legs legs arms arms but it's just one
leg
well i mean that's that's that's her
right there oh she got legs she got toes
though i don't think so it doesn't so no
fingers no toes i don't think so that's
not bad still got the stumps yeah that's
not bad she's got like knees
[ __ ]
heads shoulders knees no toes okay look
at look at he's smiling and everything
good spirit spirits man
that's how you recover
she's just
laughter's the best man kind of yeah
because they the doctor said they were
shocked by how it turned around for her
like normally that's why they were like
hey we're gonna have to get rid of this
because that's where it's going but then
it sounds like the doctors were sad like
they had a saw
oh man it's turning around you're
turning around she's getting better what
the [ __ ] the guys that i always wanted
to use this you gotta the guy got a new
saw and he wanted to try it out that's
right
i got it off the snap-on truck
it's like she seems like a cool person
though she goes i'm just trying to get
my head around why this happened and how
it happened it left me without a job in
the house i was going through a divorce
which was already costing me god damn oh
my god bro i just met a new partner and
i was finally starting from scratch and
getting somewhere and then that partner
was like you know my favorite part about
you are your favorites
he bought a ring
toe fetish
and he's like i love your [ __ ] hands
and feet dude imagine he bought a ring
and he was just like i'm gonna get this
resized
oh [ __ ]
to be a bracelet bro
people live hard lives man
there's always some [ __ ] going down you
just that's why whenever i'm at taking
news i go home going damn i'm lucky
real bro you hear stories all day i
gotta hear the worst stories
she had a cool quote she goes i would
rather my kids visit me at the hospital
bed than at my grave oh
so that's a survivor right there what a
nice lady oh bro got that mentality
she got mama mentality right yeah she's
dope man that's cool yeah she said i
shouldn't be alive given the amount of
poison i had in my blood that's crazy
sepsis i didn't even know sepsis was
that fast yeah i didn't know this that
was that fast i remember um my buddy
worked out with me and um
in the in the same night after he worked
out
he started having crazy chills right and
his wife was like dude you know what
happened i'm like now he's just doing
squats and [ __ ] and then um
in the morning he was like
like kind of coma like just stuck in his
bed and all that he was at the hospital
and then and then what finds out is that
he had an infection that kind of
started infecting his bloodstream
it was within blood infection
right yeah and then like i don't know
what
happened to cure him or whatever but
they had to like put him on all kinds of
[ __ ] antibiotics and whatever and
he's okay now but that [ __ ] happened
quick you know he just thought he was
sick
i'm like damn those squats really
[ __ ] kill them
damn like day goes hard
dude works out crazy bro there was some
kind of like a septic thing you get from
a tampon yeah so if you leave a tampon
in for too long um you can get toxic
syndrome
and you can get your legs cut off it's
very common with girls oh my god it's
common it's kind of just gonna leave it
in for two years is it just bacteria or
something yeah
it's so crazy because like when you have
a tampon in sometimes you do forget
like contacts because yeah [ __ ] stuck
inside of them too like i can't find it
sometimes like it just happens so so do
you recommend girls to use pads then and
not tampons
yeah using a cup or like yeah one of
those like bands you guys ever seen a
diva cup before no what is that can you
explain to the gentleman what a diva cup
you explain first and then we'll get the
correct one all right all right it's a
it's a it's a small little like cup it's
like probably this big maybe like the
thing on top of the tylenol uh no it's
almost it looks like a funnel kind of
but i think the bottom isn't right it's
close it's closed right okay but it's
rubber okay
and then you put it up in your vagina
when you're on your period and it
collects
the menstruation what prevents it from
like slipping out i think it's it's the
magic of the vagina so you just gravity
the cup i know it's gonna become magic
it's a circle
and the way you put it in is you um kind
of squeeze it and then you put it up
there when you let go kind of it expands
and then that's like basically like
the thing collects it yeah what if
someone makes you laugh and they quit
phone calls
you put it in that's very common too
laughs
[Laughter]
like both mouths are [ __ ] breathing
it's like a symbiotic relationship you
need to have air go up there oh the
true but air texas could have turned out
an idiot
tony's gonna grow up as an idiot
here's a scientific question what about
laughing because i heard that happens
can you shoot out the diva cup by that
way um
if you don't put it up high enough yes
because that's the same thing can happen
to a tampon okay and i've also heard
people use period panties where they
have like a oh yes those are really good
really because it really just absorbs it
and it's like reusable yeah see that so
why is that your technology is great the
diva cup's a female version of the
hustler why is that not a diva cup i
know it's kitty
is that the beyonce
you musical man
i just wanted to live life as a total
[ __ ] idiot for one minute
that's amazing that's so funny that's
the preferred method among most women
that you know diva cups um
no is that a new wave we've used tampons
because it's the most convenient yeah
the most convenient what don't you like
about pads it's nasty you're sitting in
your own blood like a diaper yeah most
chicks like if it happens they
immediately go change if they can what
the pad um
what do you mean immediately but then
you won't have one there right after you
like well i don't you know chicksaurus
like oh i'm going to the bathroom
no i don't think it like goes all out at
once and it's like whoa it's time the
impersonation of a chick all day but
those people swapping like
[Laughter]
you gotta keep the party going dude
oh i love that
that's so [ __ ] funny like the only
time where i've used pads recently is
like just a panty liner where your
period is like
light
so toward the end towards the end
yeah
we should all like if we all have
daughters we should all brainstorm how
to teach her about it oh my god guys
[ __ ] you know dad teaches his
daughter how to [ __ ] deal with her
period
my dad has to talk to me about my period
why yeah cause like when i first started
my period i was in fourth grade i was
very early
and so i got scared i didn't know what
was supposed to happen so i thought i
would get in trouble if i told my
parents so i just i kind of hid it
because you thought you were sick yeah
and so my mom was doing laundry and she
found my underwear and she calls my dad
and she was like talk to her right now
what what are you doing when she's doing
it yeah and then he like sat me down and
then he talked wait was he like driving
you to school no no no like he we were
at home
that's crazy
how come her mom didn't want to do the
talk because she was doing laundry
so how did he do how did your dad do he
was pretty good
yeah
yeah i would say like you know
sometimes he do it in vietnamese by the
way yeah yeah of course okay he was like
you know sometimes no it was so awkward
too because he caught me watching porn
like
why is it always your dad like
two weeks before and then this happened
right yes were you watching
um how did you get porn information
it was his porn oh yeah but then also
but then i also watched it i also
watched porn like on demand
[Music]
like somebody's been watching this [ __ ]
about 300. i'll be watching porn and
then like that happens like my period
happens and he's like so you've been
watching porn and then now your period
happens like what is going on you're a
woman now oh
one two combo right there let's just
deal with all of it right now he was
stressed and i was like well i don't
know which one do you want me to [ __ ]
puberty bro guys yeah
and but he was pretty cool about it
shout out to your dad like was he like
you know when you grow up first it's
like a nuke mom but then later it
becomes like sriracha you're so racist
girl
[Laughter]
it's pretty amazing how little guys like
know about this stuff and then you end
up having a dog about periods bro i wish
i had
sisters i mean it's probably a blessing
i heard about that [ __ ] yeah i would
always overhear my sister talk about and
my mom talk about their period they
don't like let you in on that
conversation you know are you guys ever
curious yeah i mean why are we asking
you i'll be asking questions yeah google
this was a good amazing twitter i mean
now like before i was curious for no
reason and now i want to know so i'm not
a total idiot when my daughter is asking
me you know right yeah definitely i'm
gonna use tobasco so i won't be racist
that's the part that you're just like i
need to still workshop this joke this
joke if i just switch the [ __ ] hot
sauces
you